donc bonjour mesdames et messieurs je
propose de commencer cette table ronde
autour des acteurs de lutte contre la
précarité énergétique donc monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues donc nous
poursuivons aujourd'hui nos travaux à
travers cette table ronde autour
d'acteurs du logement et de l'habitat
qui sont particulièrement engagés dans
la lutte contre la précarité énergétique
nous recevons ainsi des représentants de
cinq organismes et associations
l'Observatoire de la précarité
énergétique représentée par Madame
Isolde de Vallières chef de projet
précarité énergétique à l'ADEME et
coordonnatrice à l'onpe et par Madame
Lise-Marie Dambrine chargée de mission à
l'onpe l'observatoire a été créée en
2011 il assure un suivi de la précarité
énergétique en France afin d'observer et
d'analyser les politiques publiques de
lutte contre ce phénomène il y a
notamment publié fin mars le tableau de
bord et les chiffres de la précarité
pour 2022 l'association stop exclusion
énergétique représenté ici par son
délégué général monsieur Gilles Beraud
réunis de nombreuses associations et
collectivités afin de proposer des
solutions pour lutter contre la
précarité énergétique notamment en
rénovant les logements sans reste à
charge grâce à des assemblés solidaires
le réseau pro CIVIS représenté par son
directeur général monsieur Guillaume ma
chère et par Madame Clarisse d'AGNE
d'agneau Go directrice de l'engagement
sociétal et des relations
institutionnelles est un acteur de
l'économie sociale et solidaire composé
de nombreuses coopératives le réseau pro
CIVIS est présent sur toute la chaîne du
logement leur mission sociale sont
notamment vraiment engagé dans la
rénovation énergétique du parc privé à
destination des plus précaires la
Fédération Solia représentée par Madame
Juliette Laganier directrice générale et
par Madame alors j'ai pas le nom sur
Madame Cécile Guérin Delaunay qui est
responsable du pôle réhabilitation de la
Fédération Solia qui est donc un acteur
de l'économie sociale et solidaire pour
l'habitat privé à vocation sociale
composée de 135 associations la
Fédération accompagne les collectivités
des habitants afin de favoriser l'accès
et le maintien dans l'habitat des
personnes précaires et vulnérables enfin
la Fondation Abbé Pierre qui représente
ici par Monsieur Manuel d'homergue
directeur des études et par Madame
mayder Olivier chargé de plaidoyer et de
mobilisation la fondation Abbé
nécessaire de la présenter est un acteur
historique de la lutte contre le mal
logement elle mène des actions de
sensibilisation de conseils et
d'accompagnement et soutient
financièrement de nombreuses initiatives
afin d'améliorer les conditions de
logement notamment par le biais de la
rénovation énergétique mesdames et
messieurs dans vos différences
différentes fonctions que je viens de
rappeler vous agissez dans le domaine de
la lutte contre la précarité énergétique
en accompagnant les publics les plus
précaires et en proposant des solutions
de logement adaptés en 2021 11,9% des
ménages soit 3,4 millions de ménages se
sont trouvés en situation de précarité
énergétique et 22% des ménages ont
souffert du froid à majorité pour des
raisons économiques
comment la rénovation énergétique
peut-elle participer à réduire sinon
éliminer ces situations nous avons
conscience que la précarité énergétique
dépend de cause structurelles revenus
situation de vie et conjoncturelle
os des prix de l'énergie qui ne sont pas
toutes liées à l'état dégradé du
logement et à sa faible performance
énergétique toutefois en ce qui concerne
cette commission d'enquête c'est bien
sur l'aspect de la rénovation
énergétique comme levier de sortie de la
précarité que nous souhaitons échanger
avec vous aujourd'hui votre audition
dans le cadre de cette table ronde doit
nous permettre de mieux comprendre vos
positions respectives sur ce sujet
quel bilan à votre échelle faites-vous
de la politique de rénovation
énergétique en France
considérez-vous que les politiques
publiques de rénovation soit efficace
pour lutter contre la précarité
énergétique et pour orienter les plus
précaires vers des rénovations globales
si ce n'est pas le cas comment
pourrait-elle être améliorée enfin le
confort d'été est-il suffisamment pris
en compte dans la détermination de la
précarité énergétique au regard des
températures que nous aurons à affronter
dans les années à venir avant de vous
laisser la parole pour répondre à ses
premières questions et pour un propos
introductif d'environ une quinzaine de
minutes il me revient de vous indiquer
que cette audition est diffusée en
direct et en différé sur le site
internet du Sénat et qu'un sera publié
je dois également vous rappeler qu'un
faux témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des peines
prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller de 3 ans à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros à
100000 euros d'amende je vous invite
donc à prêter serment de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité a levé la main
droite et à dire je le jure donc je vous
propose peut-être de commencer
directement par vous les uns et les
autres et à bien vouloir vous prêter à
ce formalisme mais qui est obligatoire
dans le cas d'une commission d'enquête
je vous en remercie donc je vous laisse
la parole alors je ne sais pas comment
vous voulez vous distribuer la parole
pour cette présentation est-ce que
l'ordre vous convient est-ce que vous
souhaitez voilà avoir à vous de voir et
ensuite notre rapporteur nos collègues
qui sont membres de cette commission
d'enquête ne manqueront pas de vous
poser un certain nombre d'autres
questions ou de vous demander des
précisions par rapport à vos exposés
respectifs alors peut-être voilà on va
commencer par l'Observatoire national de
la précarité énergétique si vous le
voulez bien
branchez votre micro s'il vous plaît
et je vous remercie de d'avoir de nous
avoir invité effectivement
Lise-Marie Dambrine et moi-même qui
représentant donc l'Observatoire
national de la précarité énergétique je
suis donc chef de projet depuis 7 ans à
l'ADEME chef de projet précarité
énergétique et j'assure comme vous
l'avez dit le suivi de la du phénomène
de prêter énergétique son analyse aussi
bien
dans le temps que sur l'ensemble du
territoire et
l'onpe l'obser international énergétique
est un outil d'aide à la décision et
donc on fait un certain nombre de
propositions et à ce titre là on est on
est donc ravi de de d'assister et de
participer à cette commission
par rapport peut-être une question que
j'ai pu vous poser est-ce que vous
pensez aujourd'hui que justement les
connectiques qui sont menées en matière
de rénovation énergétique vous
paraissent être à la fois efficace et
surtout vu du côté de la précarité
énergétique peut-être une vue d'ensemble
après si vous le souhaitez on rentrera
plus dans le détail par rapport aux
questions de monsieur le rapporteur
alors
au vu donc des indicateurs que nous
suivons
effectivement on peut s'interroger sur
l'efficacité déficience des politiques
publiques puisque les indicateurs à
savoir le taux d'effort énergétique
c'est à dire la part donc des dépenses
d'énergie sur les revenus comme la
déclaration du froid au regard d'un
certain nombre de modalités liés à aux
conditions d'habitat et de ressources
sont en hausse
cette année comme les années précédentes
et on voit effectivement un phénomène
qui qui augmente et donc on peut de
penser que les politiques mises en
oeuvre sont pas suffisamment efficaces
même si elles ont montré un certain
nombre d'évolutions qui sont tout à fait
satisfaisantes en tout cas qui vont dans
le bon sens après je vous répondrai de
façon plus précise sur un certain nombre
d'outils qui sont suivis par
l'Observatoire national de la prière
énergétique mais ce qu'on peut constater
effectivement c'est une augmentation
grandissante du phénomène que la crise
sanitaire et la crise énergétique que
ces deux crises ont exacerbées
et donc voilà ça ça fait partie des des
chiffres qui ont été effectivement pliés
dans le dans le tableau de bord qui est
mise en ligne depuis très peu de temps
alors on avait
on avait de souhaiter faire un bilan des
10 ans du Grenelle de l'environnement
l'année dernière lors du il y a deux ans
maintenant lors du colloque
qui avait été organisé à Lille et qui
avait déjà fait état d'un certain nombre
de d'observations notamment l'empilement
la succession de différents dispositifs
qui apportait une certaine confusion
pour les opérateurs
des des seuils qui qui variaient
au fil des des années et donc
effectivement tout ça participait d'une
difficulté à bien identifier les les
l'efficacité des des dispositifs mis en
oeuvre
donc ça c'est ça c'est une première
éléments c'est effectivement on a mené
ce travail de bilan
et qui nous a permis aussi d'observer
qu'il y avait pas vraiment eu de
politique nationale de lutte contre la
précarité énergétique
à proprement dite mais effectivement
des politiques différentes qui qui d'une
part traitait
les impayés d'énergie qui sont
effectivement une des causes ou une des
conséquences pardon de la plaquette
énergétique et d'autre part des
politiques de rénovation du bâtiment
on avait donc quand je dis on c'est
l'ensemble des 30 partenaires qui sont
membres de l'Observatoire National
énergétique dont sollia et la Fondation
Abbé Pierre ici présent qui donc nous
avons fait un certain nombre de
propositions dans le cas d'une
déclaration collective qui est en ligne
sur le site de l'onpe et qui faisait
valoir la nécessité d'avoir un référent
sur la précarité énergétique
de façon à pouvoir effectivement
assurer avec ce référent se déléguer à
terme ministériel
l'assurance de d'une politique
ambitieuse avec des
des objectifs à remplir et un certain
nombre de moyens à mettre en oeuvre pour
y parvenir voilà donc ça c'était une des
propositions effectivement entre temps
la crise surtout la guerre en
Ukraine à rendu les différentes
à mobiliser un certain nombre de
ministères sur cette question de la
hausse des prix notamment effectivement
la mise en œuvre d'un bouclier tarifaire
reportant peut-être la
le lancement d'une politique de lutte
contre la énergétique claire et
ambitieuse et donc il est temps
aujourd'hui de poser ce problème et de
faire en sorte qu'il y a une politique
plus claire plus lisible et des moyens
sans doute plus plus adaptés à ces
enjeux
merci peut-être vous voulez rajouter
quelque chose madame ou à ce stade non
d'accord alors Monsieur Béraud peut-être
à vous
merci cette invitation et nous
intéresser aussi directement au sujet y
compris dans la formulation de la
question effectivement on est pas à
l'aise par rapport à ce sujet parce que
effectivement c'est totalement
insupportable dans un pays comme la
France avoir des gens en très très
grande précarité on a identifié
uniquement sur la priorité de notre
action c'est à dire les les
propriétaires occupants de maisons
individuelles ils sont plus de 500 000
en France à être dans à vivre dans des
passoires thermiques et dans des
conditions économiques absolument
terribles et c'est un sujet extrêmement
mobilisateur maintenant puisque quand on
agit sur le social et les plus précaires
on a des gains pour le climat on
améliore la santé des gens et on crée de
l'emploi local alors dit comme ça ça
semble extrêmement simple dans la
réalité c'est infiniment complexe parce
qu'effectivement qu'on dit que ces
multiples bénéfices ça l'est aussi dans
l'action et on a vraiment le sentiment
qu'on n'a jamais autant fait dans ce
pays et je parle autant des
collectivités locales des territoires
des entreprises que de l'État mais que à
l'échelle de ce qui est en train de se
passer des évolutions bien sûr du prix
de l'énergie mais aussi des dérèglements
climatiques qui augmentent les
problématiques on pourrait faire le lien
beaucoup travaillé sur les questions
climatiques quand je préside le Comité
21 on est à la fois dans le constat et
dans les modes de résolution dans des
approches extrêmement transversales et
complexes donc on considère que
effectivement on fait beaucoup mais que
la question c'est évidemment de de faire
que les courbes se croisent c'est à dire
les gens qui plongent dans des
situations de très grandes précarité
énergétiques nous on est plutôt ce que
j'allais dire spécialisé c'est le terme
est peut-être excessif mais notre focus
est vraiment sur les gens très très
grande difficulté en gros les gens qui
vivent avec moins de 10 euros par jour
et par personne et qui souffrent du
froid les enfants sont plus malades que
les autres enfin je vais pas rentrer
dans les chiffres je pense
qu'effectivement beaucoup de chiffres va
être partagé quels sont les éléments sur
lequel
il n'a pas été travaillé suffisamment
probablement et en tout cas il faut
travailler en priorité ce que je vais
vous dire en quelques minutes et dans un
scénario que nous juste de publier c'est
quelques années de travail pardon j'ai
deux exemplaires papier mais je pourrais
l'envoyer évidemment numérique ou plus
d'exemplaires papier si vous le
souhaitez mais c'est quel scénario pour
éradiquer la grande exclusion
énergétique à 2030 on se réfère
évidemment à l'agenda des objectifs de
développement durable le premier point
c'est la capacité à créer des alliances
multiacteurs locales c'est de la
collaboration entre collectivités
entreprises ONG que peuvent naître les
résultats et nous la montée au niveau
national on est maintenant 60
organisations membres qui cooperont tous
les jours qui ont coélaboré ce scénario
mais évidemment faut faire la même chose
au niveau local j'étais avec la mairie
de Tourcoing tout à l'heure on est en
train de travailler à cette alliance
locale ça c'est le premier point
l'approche systémique territoriale
malheureusement elle a peu été mis en
place mais faut aussi comprendre que si
aujourd'hui on parle encore plus de
précarité énergétiques mais c'est un
sujet assez nouveau et c'est un sujet
aussi nouveau dans la capacités
d'alliance de mise en oeuvre on a monté
une campagne de mobilisation sur le
sujet avec une artiste en l'occurrence
Emmanuel Béart il y a 3 ans on s'est
rendu compte que évidemment la Fondation
Abbé Pierre et autres nous explique que
les gens ont froid souffrent mais dans
le mode de résolution c'est un sujet
complètement nouveau et je crois que ça
explique aussi certaines difficultés en
tout cas on a du mal à créer ces
alliances locales le deuxième point
c'est l'accompagnement
enfin je vais dire le métier
d'accompagnement est reconnu
on espère beaucoup de mon accompagnateur
Renov renforcé en collabore évidemment
avec la NAS sur le sujet aujourd'hui
quand
on veut accompagner une famille en très
très grande précarité c'est un métier
nous l'appelle ensemble et solidaire la
première promotion vient de sortir la
semaine dernière seulement 10 on va en
former plus de 300 dans les deux années
qui viennent et le dispositif va
permettre de donner une pérennité
économique à ce métier voilà on va le
développer fortement en éthique on vient
de gagner un appel
certificat d'économie d'énergie qui va
être centrée vraiment sur la création
des territoires zéros fusion
énergétiques mais qui va permettre de
financer l'accompagnement de 3000
familles 3000 familles ça peut vous
paraître peu mais l'année dernière je
crois que la NA financé 1700 rénovations
globale et performante chez des grands
précaires en France mais c'est une
croûte très grande difficulté il faut
parfois un an ou deux ans et des
ensembler solidaires à qu'on peut qui
accompagne le Secours Catholique les
CCAS et autres à rentrer chez les gens à
créer ses climats de confiance c'est pas
de la technicité de la technologie etc
c'est d'abord de l'humain et des
logiques de confiance et pour ça que les
collectivités locales ont un rôle aussi
important mais il faut l'outil y est il
fait le financer on espère beaucoup on
attend le montant de mon accompagnateur
renforcé patiemment parce que
effectivement faut si on est en dessous
de 5000 5500 euros on n'y arrivera pas
en tout cas le financer que comme ça
l'autre troisième point c'est celui du
financement vous l'avez dit en ouverture
nous on milite pour une prise en charge
quasi intégrale du financement quasi
intégral y compris chez les
propriétaires des fois on réfléchit en
se disant mais comment ça se fait on va
augmenter la valeur capitalistique d'une
famille non je crois que ça n'existe pas
le
logement où on habite n'est pas n'a pas
de montant n'a pas c'est des conditions
de vie et ce n'est pas
le temps d'héritage et c'est avant tout
des conditions de vie et il faut je
crois méditer fortement non pas pour
100% parce que pour des questions
dignité et à t'aider car mondes qui
travaillent avec nous dit nous dit
toujours non surtout jamais 100% parce
que c'est une question de dignité c'est
parfois un geste parfois voilà ça
c'était le troisième point pour financer
ça indépendamment des dispositifs
publics
notamment ce que mène Lana dans les
territoires d'accélération il y a six
départements concernés en France dont
certains qui marchent très bien où là
les montants sont pas du tout les mêmes
quand on s'adresse aux très grand
précaire et je crois qu'il faut
généraliser cette démarche je sais que
la nail réfléchit mais c'est important
il y a d'autres éléments de d'autres
dispositifs à favoriser fortement qui
sont insuffisants pour l'instant je
pense aux caisses d'avance pour
permettre de gérer la trésorerie et
rassurer les familles savoir qu'une
famille en grande précarité quand il y a
une subvention de 2000 euros du conseil
général qui arrive sur le compte on dort
pas et l'obsession à qui je le reverse
pour pas les perdre voilà donc on est
vraiment sur ces caisses d'avance et je
crois qu'il y a aussi beaucoup à faire
sur la compensation carbone aujourd'hui
on a du mal à adresser la belle ba
carbone bien sûr c'est important de
replanter des forêts mais je crois qu'il
y a des dispositifs aussi à inventer ils
sont parfois difficiles à des questions
de cohérence pardon d'être un peu
technique mais mettre des économies
d'énergie avec des économies de carbone
sur le même budget je sais que c'est
complexe et alors je crois qu'il y a
aussi dans l'administration des gens qui
savent très très bien gérer genre de
problème il y a un autre point qui est
favorisé l'auto réhabilitation
accompagnée parce que porte fortement
les Compagnons Bâtisseurs au sein de
notre organisation voilà donc ça c'est
les quatre premiers points il y a un
autre point qui est la qualité des
travaux on a un problème de qualité des
travaux les malgré
la volonté d'artisans le RGE etc mais
pour ça il faut aussi que les politiques
publiques soient plus pérennes c'est à
dire que quand on parle de programme
certificat d'économie d'énergie sur des
sujets qui dure 5 ans et qui sont remis
en cause évidemment le rôle de la DGEC
c'est d'éviter des effets d'aubaine
voire des sujets qui s'apprêtent à
l'escroquerie mais maintenant si on veut
impliquer plus de monde plus
d'entreprises y compris des plus grosses
il faut donner plus de visibilité et
peut-être même que des programmes de des
périodes de certificat d'économie
d'énergie pour être plus large plus
longue ce qui permettrait aussi à des
entreprises de mieux s'organiser nous
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on crée ces
territoires zéro exclusions énergétiques
c'est pour dire des artisans mais c'est
pas deux ou trois chantiers c'est 10 20
35 ans sans qu'il va falloir gérer sur
les trois ans et là on peut commencer à
discuter sérieusement notamment dans le
contexte aussi d'augmentation du coût
qui est évidemment très importante et
rassurez-vous j'ai presque fini mais
la question aussi c'est celle de compter
l'obligation des certificats d'économie
d'énergie on pense qu'il y en a pas
assez la baisse des coûts actuels est
dangereuse pour la lutte contre la
précarité énergétique et une des
solutions c'est d'augmenter cette
obligation évidemment certaines
entreprises n'y sont pas très
enthousiastes mais c'est probablement
une priorité et enfin il y a un peu
technicité à droite et à gauche il faut
probablement simplifier aussi
des process
lagrément de certaines entreprises et
associations sur à des dispositifs
notamment le marc qui arrive pour les
associations je pense qu'il y a un peu
de et encore une fois on est en
conscience que il faut évidemment éviter
tout est fait d'aubaine et escroquerie
etc parce que c'est de l'argent en moins
pour aider des familles et gagner sur le
climat
aussi d'autres points techniques qu'il
faudra travailler je vais prendre juste
un petit exemple pour finir on est
l'association est très récente elle est
née en 2020 en 2020 on avait des projets
qui arrivaient à 50 70 000 euros qui
étaient des vrais rénovations globales
et performantes exactement à l'identique
dans le même condition on est on est à
20 à 25000 euros de plus quoi et de plus
en plus de notamment ni le France
arrivait à 100 000 mais si vous arrivez
à 100000 il faut il faut une maîtrise
d'oeuvre et donc vous prenez 10% de plus
donc peut-être que il y a aussi des
aménagements à faire pour que le même
métier ferme les mêmes opérateurs qui
font de la très grande qualité et je
pense à do ré mi et cohabitat les
compagnons Solia etc et bien on puisse
aménager aussi les choses parce que les
les parce que le prix brut des choses
augmentent voilà donc en gros on n'a
jamais autant fait mais c'est vraiment
le moment d'accélérer parce que la
situation des plus en difficulté
augmente du fait effectivement
de tout ce qui s'est passé et quand on
vivait le covid il faut pas oublier que
c'est pour certains d'entre nous c'était
une bonne nouvelle de voir la télévision
que les émissions de carbone baisse
les pollution baisse pour d'autres qui
étaient obligés de rester chez eux
c'était être soumis encore plus
longtemps par jour à des mauvaises
qualités de l'air intérieur qui rendent
malade merci Merci à VOUS AUSSI vice
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs peut-être quelques mots sur
proxybis pour nous resituer dire quelle
est la légitimité qu'elle a notre a
répondu aux questions vous nous posez
donc pour civil c'est un réseau de
coopérative il y en a 46 sur tout le
territoire national métropolitain c'est
coopérative opère sur tous les métiers
du logement nous sommes selon les
classements le 7e ou le 8e promoteur
national nous sommes le deuxième
constructeur de maison et nous sommes le
4e administrateur de bien nous sommes
aussi l'une des cinq familles
constitutives de l'Union sociale pour
l'habitat et nous avons en propre un
certain nombre de SH et Coop ce qui fait
de nous aussi d'ailleurs social ça c'est
pour notre activité économique nous
sommes comme l'a dit madame la
Présidente en introduction
un acteur de l'économie sociale et
solidaire donc la deuxième jambe à côté
de cette activité économique c'est une
activité sociale
l'essentiel des richesses que produit
ces activités économiques nous les
réemployons à des fins d'utilité sociale
dans des activités d'intérêt général
concrètement nous sommes en convention
en partenariat avec le ministère du
logement pour préfinancer un certain
nombre d'aides publiques nationales et
locales nous faisons exactement qui
était appelé à l'instant de ses vœux par
mon voisin c'est-à-dire des caisses
d'avance c'est-à-dire que on a bien
conscience que des ménages modestes et
très modestes notamment au sens de
l'Anah
ne sont pas capables de faire ces
avances de trésorerie par rapport à
l'arrivée de la subvention donc nous
faisons ce joint si je puis dire pour
que la décision de rénovation puisse
être prise par des ménages
indépendamment de leur situation
économique
voilà alors sur les différentes
questions que vous avez
soulevé dans votre propos liminaire bon
nous déjà on aurait quand même plutôt
tendance à saluer au moins la prise de
conscience
politique entendue au sens large autour
de la question de la rénovation
énergétique il y a quand même de
l'argent public qui est mis sur cette
question là le fait même que cette
commission existe aujourd'hui montre
bien que c'est une préoccupation des des
élus et des pouvoirs publics aux
différents niveaux
si on était un tout petit peu
taquin je dirais même que par rapport à
une situation du marché du logement qui
est très détériorée sur plein d'aspects
il me semble que c'est justement la
question de la rénovation énergétique
qui surnage dans le discours et dans
l'action publique alors qu'il y a tout
un tas d'autres sujets d'accès au
logement qui pourraient aussi se poser
et qui nous semble traiter avec moins
d'énergie
par rapport à cette question de la
rénovation énergétique
une série de difficultés
certaines ont déjà été évoquées si on
doit vraiment résumer résumer nous notre
position on envoie deux majeurs la
question du financement
et la question de la décision notamment
de la décision en copropriété
la question du financement bon elle
était déjà plusieurs fois abordé donc
nous on essaye mais très modestement d'y
prendre notre part avec cette histoire
de prime de financement des aides de
public etc bon très bien peut-être qu'on
peut
accroître encore cette intervention on a
des discussions avec des partenaires
potentiels à la demande du ministère du
logement notamment avec la banque des
territoires pour voir comment on peut
massifier cette loi la mode cette ce
système de préfinancement
ce qui nous apparaît quand même c'est
qu'il y a un défaut d'argent privé dans
le monde financement de la Réunion
énergétique et notamment que
le secteur bancaire même je pense qu'il
est plein de bonnes volonté qu'il a été
sollicité par les par les ministères
semble avoir du mal malgré tout à
déployer une offre à Doc et une offre
qui fasse mouche parce qu'il y a des
dispositifs qui existent aujourd'hui
ils coupaient des aides prévention etc
mais on voit bien que les volumes ne
sont pas complètement encore au
rendez-vous donc on a plusieurs
propositions à faire par rapport à ce
sujet du financement à la fois sur
l'amélioration des dispositifs existants
et sur la création d'un outil Haddock
juste un mot avant d'y revenir si vous
le souhaitez mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs nous il nous apparaît que on a
besoin d'une banque de place une banque
qui serait dédiée à la rénovation
énergétique une banque dans laquelle les
banques commerciales pour être les
principaux actionnaires ce qui leur
permettrait de répondre à la taxonomie
européenne et donc de titriser
un certain volume de créance verte donc
ça répond à une problématique du secteur
bancaire et à la fois ça répond à une
problématique politique et sociale de
trouver des financements pour la
rénovation énergétique y compris sur des
montants petits qui sont des montants
sur lesquels voilà encore une fois de
dispositif bancaire tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui n'est pas approprié c'est
pas avec des prêts à la consommation
avec des taux voilà 7 8 etc qu'on va
pouvoir répondre à cette à cet enjeu je
peux revenir sur cette première idée
dans la suite de nos échanges bon sur le
préavance mutation il apparaît qu'il y a
des conditions qui sont extrêmement
restrictives à la fois sur les sur les
ressources sur le statut du demandeur
nous on serait plutôt partisans de lever
ces restrictions mais aussi une
difficulté qui est que certains nombre
de demandeurs sont des personnes âgées
et que les banques ne savent pas traiter
forcément la question du du temps long
dans ces dans ces circonstances bon on
pourra aussi revenir plus en détail donc
ça c'est un premier champ de difficulté
le financement deuxième sans difficulté
la prise de décision et notamment au
logement collectif
la situation actuelle est quand même que
les absents des assemblées générales de
copropriété ont une influence
déterminante dans la non prise de
décision
j'avais dit dans un papier sous forme de
boutade finalement les absents toujours
raison en espèces et qu'il faudrait
trouver sans doute un mécanisme
différent qui
qui incite très fortement les
copropriétaires à prendre par au vote ou
alors à ce que la décision se prenne
sans eux pourra revenir sur les
histoires Artigues 25 article 24
de la loi 65 bon
il y a une question un peu
philosophique mais qui amène à des
conséquences de mon point de vue très
pratique en termes de politique publique
c'est qui est responsable de la
situation actuelle c'est-à-dire
cette prise de conscience et là on va
demander maintenant à des propriétaires
de remettre à l'endroit des choses qui
étaient de travers c'est un coup
considérable et donc il faut voir qui
assume ce coup et donc il faut sans
doute trouver par rapport aux questions
qui nous avaient été adressées par mail
ce qu'il faut sans doute trouver un
équilibre entre des formes d'obligation
et des formes d'incitation l'une et
l'autre n'étant pas exclusive d'ailleurs
mais ça nous semble compliqué de tout
faire porter sur les propriétaires
actuels du logement il faut penser le
temps long il faut peut-être aussi
penser
l'existence notamment du logement
collectif comme une personne morale on
pourra également développer ce point si
vous le souhaitez
dans la continuité de ce que je viens de
dire nous apparaît aussi que ce qui
pourrait inciter les propriétaires les
copropriétaires à faire ces travaux
importants de rénovation énergétique
c'est que ces travaux génèrent de la
valeur
qui s'y retrouve économiquement et donc
nous on pense qu'il faut réfléchir en
même temps qu'on fait la rénovation
énergétique à la manière dont on peut
doter les logements de nouvelles sources
de production d'énergie que l'on parle
de panneaux solaires sur les toits que
l'on parle
de chaudière hydrogène il y a des choses
sans doute à imaginer à ces moments-là
on peut aussi penser à la surélévation
aujourd'hui selon les estimations
60% de tiers des PLU qui sont exploités
dans le sens potentiel du PNL qui sont
exploités peut-être que c'est l'occasion
d'exploiter plus fortement le PMU et là
les copropriétaires pourraient y
retrouver
une équation
économique tenant pour eux
et enfin je rejoins complètement mon
voisin une fois qu'on a levé toutes ces
difficultés qui ne sont pas minces se
posent la présence d'un appareil
productif suffisamment solide
si on pense comme c'est notre cas qu'il
faut continuer à construire un volume
important
de 350 000 logements
par an parce qu'il y a quand même des
problématiques sociales qui ne
disparaissent pas du fait des
problématiques et écologiques émergentes
mais quand même temps il faut quand même
rénover tout le parc
très grande partie du parc
il y a du pain sur la planche et donc là
il faut trouver les bras pour pour
répondre aux défis considérables je vous
remercie merci Sonia
merci d'avoir convié Solia à cette
audition puisqu'effectivement les
associations de notre réseau disposent
d'une expertise assez fine sur les
enjeux de rénovation énergétique en tant
que opérateur historique de Lana donc ça
fait plusieurs années qu'on
œuvre sur sur ces questions-là
de notre côté si nous partageons des
constats qui ont été posés tant par le
NPE
par gilbero nous souhaitons pour notre
part ça lui ait le virage qui a pu être
pris par les pouvoirs publics ces
derniers temps et le changement
d'échelle qu'il induit mais
effectivement il est nécessaire
maintenant d'accélérer le mouvement et
nous sommes qu'il y a quelques freins
qui pourraient sur lesquels il faudrait
travailler rapidement
globalement nous restons inquiets sur le
fait que les ménages modestes et très
modestes bénéficient bien des
dispositifs qui les concernent et
notamment à la hauteur des enjeux
puisque
voilà aujourd'hui nous semble
indispensable qui puisse bénéficier des
rénovations globales et performantes de
leur logement et pas uniquement des
rénovations par gestes qui aujourd'hui
semblent être les les actions les plus
courantes les plus couramment mis en
œuvre ma prime rénove scénarité a fait
ses preuves en termes de gains
énergétique mais par contre les
ambitions chiffrées le NPE la redy ne
sont pas au rendez-vous
la rénovation par geste elle a le mérite
d'exister mais elle ne permet pas
d'atteindre ni nos ambitions de justice
sociale ni nos ambitions de justice
climatique l'enjeu pour nous et que les
et que désormais l'accent soit mis sur
le dispositif MPRs notamment pour les
propriétaires occupants et pour cela on
y voit on a cinq cinq sujets
d'inquiétude ou de leviers on peut le
prendre dans le sens souhaité d'une part
sur l'accompagnement évoqué par par
gilberaud effectivement nous avons de
notre côté aussi l'intime conviction que
la réussite de la massification passera
par cette accompagnement mais non pas un
accompagnement standardisé mais un
accompagnement personnalisé qui puisse
répondre ou à la diversité des
situations des ménages et aujourd'hui
nous sommes inquiets puis sur les enjeux
de financement de cet accompagnement sur
lesquels on a toujours pas de réponse
alors qu'on est à moins de 6 mois de la
mise en place du dispositif Marc et donc
aujourd'hui très concrètement ça impacte
les ménages qui qui viennent frapper à
la porte de nos associations et pour
lesquelles on est en difficulté pour
leur proposer de disposer d'une
visibilité concrète sur un plan de
financement qui puisse répondre à leurs
projets le donc premier point ce serait
de pouvoir disposer enfin de ces
arbitrages qui nous permettent et qui
permettent surtout au ménage de disposer
de la visibilité attendue le deuxième
point c'est les concerne les outils
financiers qui permettent de
solvabiliser les ménages donc
effectivement on a la chance sur
certains d'autres territoires de pouvoir
bén éficier du soutien de crossivisme en
matière de préfinancement des projets on
voit bien que ça permet d'enclencher en
tous les cas d'intégrer certains ménages
qui qui pourraient ne pas rentrer dans
le processus qui leur est proposé mais
aujourd'hui effectivement il y a un
enjeu de
de massification en tous les cas de
généralisation de ce dispositif là on
réfléchit également sur la question du
reste à charge aujourd'hui on est
effectivement nous non plus pas sur le
soi et la volonté d'un resta charge
à zéro mais plutôt d'un reste à charge
qu'on appelle nous supportables pour les
ménages avec des réflexions qui pour sur
cette question là
l'idée de ne pas être sur reste à charge
avec une proportion similaire par pour
tous mais bien adapté et c'est pour ça
qu'on utilise cette terminologie de
supportable pour les ménages
le troisième axe qui
qui nous semble important de sur
lesquels nous sommes importants de
réfléchir c'est sur
l'attractivité du dispositif MPRs
aujourd'hui
il nous semble que pour aller sur ces
rénovations globales performantes il
faudrait rendre le dispositif MPRs plus
attractive et plus avantageux que neympr
et voilà et en faire très clairement et
objectivement l'outil
de nos ambitions partagées le quatrième
levier c'est on en revient et on évoque
nous aussi la question des C2E il nous
semble qu'il est nécessaire de redonner
un vrai rôle d'accompagnement en ces
deux œufs en réintégrant leur gestion et
leur valorisation au sein de Lana on
sait qu'il y a là des potentialités
claires de financement de projet mais il
faut retrouver le moyen de les mobiliser
et de les mobiliser le plus largement
possible
le cinquième levier pour nous et la
capacité à disposer d'une vision plus
Riquet annuelle des crédits de Lana
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas et sans
cela on a beaucoup de mal et beaucoup de
difficultés à donner de la visibilité
et de la stabilité au ménage qu'on soit
là dans des projets
enfin voilà visibilité de la stabilité
pardon au ménage enfin il nous semble
qu'il y a aussi un enjeu de
rééquilibrage des moyens qui sont à
redéfinir aujourd'hui les moyens
financiers sont principalement mis sur
des propriétaires occupants et on a des
questions de rééquilibrage et
d'attractivité à réfléchir
collectivement pour que ce centre
concerné les propriétaires bailleurs
bien évidemment et comme les voguiquais
Guillaume machin les copropriétés
aujourd'hui on a nous aussi le constat
d'une difficulté à embarquer les
copropriétés et les copropriétés
notamment celles en
dégradé sur ces cette question de la
rénovation énergétique
enfin il nous semble qu'il faut
maintenir les à l'unisson qu'on soit
état administration opérateurs et
collectivités territoriale notre
objectif que notre objectif partager et
bien celui de la rénovation globale et
performante et que sans une convergence
de l'ensemble de des acteurs et des
financements sur cet objectif nous
aurons du mal à l'atteindre
merci beaucoup la Fondation Abbé Pierre
merci madame la Présidente pour
l'invitation et messieurs mesdames les
sénateurs et sénatrices bon je vais pas
répéter plusieurs choses qui ont été
dites par nos collègues mais le point
principal pour la Fondation Abbé Pierre
c'est qu'il faut on salue également les
efforts qui sont mis sur la rénovation
thermique ces dernières années mais il
faut aussi changer de cap et mettre
vraiment tous les moyens sur la
rénovation globale
ma collègue parlait de la de ma prime
rénove sérénité il existe aussi le
forfait rénovation globale au sein de ma
prime rénov qui dont les chiffres
aujourd'hui sont vraiment dérisoires on
parle de autour de 2000 rénovations
globales par an sur alors que on parle
de plutôt de l'ordre de plusieurs
centaines de milliers de de gestes
chaque année il y a eu un léger
rattrapage en 2022 mais qui reste bien
insuffisant puisque encore 86% des
dossiers ma prime rénov étaient des
monogestes pourtant on sait que les
rénovations globale sont les plus
efficaces en termes d'économie d'énergie
et d'économie de gaz à effet de serre
des missions de gaz à effet de serre et
voilà puisque elles permettent pour
obtenir ce forfait rénovation globale il
faut
assurer au moins 55% de réduction de
consommation d'énergie donc nous voilà
le fondation est Pierre on porte
vraiment en plaidoyer pour que
maintenant toutes les incitations soient
que ce soit fléchés pour la rénovation
globale et du coup il faut lever tous
les obstacles aujourd'hui par exemple on
a sûrement des tous entendu parler de
ces situations où on met des pompes à
chaleur dans des logements qui dont la
l'isolation n'est pas faite donc on
pourrait par exemple commencer par
exiger que pour le changement d'un
système de chauffage l'isolation du
logement soit absolument nécessaire au
moins vérifié que cette isolation est
faite et en fait du coup ça nous mène au
sujet de l'accompagnement puisque si ces
aberrations sont possibles c'est que
l'accompagnement aujourd'hui est
insuffisant la fondation dans mes
pierres avaient mené une étude auprès
des guichets ferres qui sont devenus
France rénov et dont les résultats sont
assez alarmants puisque 40% des appels
étaient non décrochés 62% des contacts
établis étaient établis sans obtenir de
conseils il y avait des délais de
réponse à rallonge de plusieurs mois et
des erreurs dans les conseils délivrés
également un lien avec Lana qui se
faisait pas toujours et difficilement
au sujet de mon accompagnateur rénov on
a du coup de beaucoup d'espoir mais qui
doit aller avec des garanties il est
absolument essentiel que cet
accompagnement soit gratuit on parlait
manuel d'homerg parlera des questions de
reste à charge mais ce dispositif peut
pas être ne peut pas être efficace si il
n'est pas gratuit neutre et il faut
remettre les moyens dans cet
accompagnement pour pas refaire les
mêmes erreurs de précédent
accompagnement qui existent et dont on a
souligné les insuffisances et qui en
fait permettent pas de d'adresser le
problème
un petit mot sur la précarité soviétique
d'été ou confort d'été la Fondation
ripière on se mobilise sur ce sujet on
prépare une étude qui devrait sortir
bientôt notamment aujourd'hui il manque
dans les barèmes de ma prime rénove des
aménagements qui permettent d'adresser
cette question du confort d'été et c'est
souvent les rénovations qui sont faites
peuvent être un peu une occasion manquée
d'aussi permettre l'habitabilité du
logement pendant l'été il y a un risque
aussi de mal adaptation du logement si
on l'adapte si les rénové en prenant en
compte que les questions de froid il est
possible que ça aggrave la situation
pendant l'été donc il est vraiment
essentiel de penser la précarité
énergétique sous ces deux facettes donc
le froid et la chaleur voilà on a déjà
plus sondé Lana la mairie de Paris et
des élus sur ce sujet et on voit que
c'est un sujet qui qui inquiète et qui
mobilise donc faut qu'on soit au
rendez-vous et donc il y a aussi un
manque de d'indicateurs d'évaluation et
d'études sur le sujet auquel on espère
que certains acteurs pourront pourront
répondre et je laisse la parole à mon
collègue manuel de merde
là on voit que peut-être à un moment on
disait les petits gestes c'est c'est
toujours utile mais si ça détourne
l'attention et les moyens publics et les
moyens de communication de ce qui marche
réellement c'est quand même ça devient
contre-productif ce qui marche aussi
c'est la rénovation HLM sans grande
surprise et pour le coup pour en avoir
beaucoup parlé avec l'Union sociale pour
l'habitat quand on se demandait si on
met si on met des milliards
supplémentaires dès 2024 par exemple
est-ce que le secteur privé sera capable
de l'utiliser il y a des points
d'interrogation en tout cas si on met un
milliard de plus dans le monde HLM pour
la rénovation énergétique on sait que ce
sera utilisé et bien utilisé ça ça
partira pas dans des dividendes des
plus-values parce que c'est un secteur
par définition à but non lucratif là où
on est très inquiet c'est que vous le
connaissez très bien aussi bien que nous
c'est le contexte financier du monde HLM
avec la hausse drastique du taux de
livret A LA la RLS qui continue la TVA
qu'augmenter et donc est-ce que les HLM
seront capables
monter encore en puissance comme ils
l'ont fait ces dernières années c'est
vraiment pas sûr du tout dans le snap il
y a une aide à la pierre de 4000 euros
ça a été voté là par logement rénové
4000 euros c'est-à-dire qu'on finance
moins les logements sociaux qui logent
les personnes les plus précaires que des
ménages intermédiaires ou même aisés
pour faire cette rénovation énergétique
donc là on sait que si on veut accélérer
il faut mettre l'accent dessus et puis
sur ma prime rénov général on va dire on
a un gros problème de reste à charge ça
a été dit également c'est un des
obstacles importants au passage à la
rénovation globale c'est que quand on
veut mener des travaux qui coûtent
rapidement ça a été dit aussi 50000 70
80.000 euros si vous avez un reste à
charge ce qui est le cas pour les très
modestes de 35% ou pour les modèles de
plus de 50%. on a on arrive à des sommes
qui sont
démesurées évidemment qui bloquent
complètement le passage à la rénovation
globale quand et même pour des des
gestes relativement simple mais qui sont
quand même plus ambitieux que simplement
changer la chaudière isoler un mur quand
vous êtes un ménage au SMIC le reste à
charge il est de 9000 euros bon qui a
9000 euros d'Épargne à mettre pour
isoler ses murs c'est quand même assez
assez compliqué et un point c'est que
nous souvent à la avec notre programme
SOS dit on essaie de faire de la
rénovation énergétique mais aussi de la
lutte contre l'habitat indigne parce que
souvent les deux problématiques se
conjuguent dans un même logement et donc
vont augmenter les coûts il est très
difficile aujourd'hui de conjuguer les
aides et donc on doit choisir entre
faire une rénovation énergétique ou
sortir de l'insalubrité et parfois ça
mène à des projets assez incohérents où
on a une très bonne performance
énergétique dans un logement indigne
donc ça c'est très embêtant la Fondation
est Pierre parfois quand elle le peut
mais au pot pour le le tour de table
rajoute 15000 20.000 euros mais
évidemment on peut pas généraliser à
toutes les personnes qui en auraient
besoin donc ça a été dit et vraiment il
faut le répéter et si ça peut sortir de
cette commission d'enquête comme un
message un peu unanime d'avoir des
financements pluriannuels sur la
rénovation énergétique c'est le cas pour
l'enroule par exemple c'est aussi
important de faire la rénovation
énergétique ça permettrait alors pour
pas développer ce sujet mais d'aider la
filière à se former à recruter des
jeunes dans la filière de la rénovation
énergétique performante si alors il y a
plein d'actions de formation nécessaire
mais si on sait que chaque année l'état
mettra un milliard d'euros par exemple
supplémentaire dans la rénovation
énergétique pendant les 5 prochaines
années on sait qu'il y a là une filière
qui va embaucher qui va former avec avec
des débouchés intéressants ce sera
important également ça a été dit pour
financer l'accompagnement aujourd'hui on
ne sait pas ce que sera le financement
au 1er janvier 2024 et pour le coup je
sais qu'il y a plein de propositions qui
ont été développées ici notamment de
financer entièrement la rénovation
énergétique par l'anticipation des gains
de performance énergétique on sait bien
que notamment vu la hausse des coûts de
construction que ça ne financera pas
intégralement le prix de la rénovation
énergétique il faut assumer que rénover
les passoires énergétiques et tous les
logements français qui aurez besoin
Coutras de l'argent public et ça a des
répercussions positives alors en termes
de gains énergétique donc on peut mettre
à contribution les ménages qui le
peuvent à ce titre là mais pas
complètement ça a des gains en termes de
réduction des dépenses de soins etc etc
qui justifient que l'État mette les
milliards supplémentaires sans que ce
soit des des sommes extravagantes si on
compare avec le périnée rue par exemple
dans la rue on parle de Somme à peu près
équivalente et c'était un chantier très
important mais voilà la rénovation
énergétique est un chantier aussi
important pour l'État et l'État est
garant du temps long et c'est vrai que
les ménages n'ont pas cette capacité à
se projeter ne serait-ce qu'à 5 ou 10
ans alors que l'État peut calculer à 30
ou 40 ans et avec l'initiative rénovant
nous avons montré qu'il y avait des
retours sur investissement pour l'État
en termes de recettes fiscale de
dépenses de soins etc à investir
fortement dans la rénovation énergétique
et puis un dernier point parce que ça
pas été abordé on a beaucoup plaidé ces
dernières années avec en ayant obtenu
gaincos pour l'obligation de rénover les
passeurs énergétiques en location et je
sais que c'est il y a des vents
contraires importants en ce moment parce
qu'évidemment on entre dans la réalité
on entre dans le dur et donc des
personnes qui des groupes qui n'y ont
pas intérêt ou en tout cas qui sont qui
sont inquiets on peut le comprendre mais
on a fait le constat que la simple
incitation pour les bailleurs privés ne
suffisait pas pour quelque chose qui est
indépassable c'est que c'est le bailleur
qui finance et qui décide la rénovation
et c'est son locataire qui en profite
donc forcément s'il n'y a pas des normes
qui qui augmentent petit à petit on
passera pas à l'action et on sait que
dans les copropriétés qui sont à des
endroits où il y a vraiment un point
faible de la rénovation énergétique
c'est en grande partie où c'était en
grande partie parce que les bailleurs
privés n'y avaient pas forcément intérêt
c'est c'est compréhensible et un des
effets déjà positifs des premières
échéances de rénovation c'est que les
bailleurs s'intéressent à la rénovation
énergétique contact les allées que les
les espaces conseillent faire les
françaisnov pour dire il paraît que je
vais être obligé que je suis déjà obligé
comment faire à quoi est-ce que j'ai
droit et l'État a bien répondu il y a
une doublement du déficit foncier
l'ouverture de vos bailleurs on a quand
même maintenant des aides qui sont très
importantes qui sont peu connues parce
que on a beaucoup entendu le discours
catastrophiste tout va être interdit à
la location il faut vendre etc alors que
les solutions sont vraiment à portée de
main et puis les bailleurs comme il faut
le rappeler à 90 % sont des des ménages
qui appartiennent aux couches les plus
aisés de la population alors il en reste
10 ou 15% mais donc des aides existent
et on peut les améliorer il y a pas de
mais en majorité ils ont les moyens de
payer en partie cette rénovation
énergétique ceux qui ont les moyens ceux
qui n'ont pas les moyens on plaide pour
eux comme pour les propriétés occupants
pour en reste à charge minime ou 0 ou
proche de zéro simplement parce que sans
ça on sait que les travaux ne décolle
pas donc on voit qu'il faut assumer que
ce soit une priorité avec de l'argent
public et ça c'est l'État qui peut le
faire il y a eu beaucoup de
d'outils pour financer la rénovation
énergétique qui amène de la confusion de
l'incertitude je pense au quota carbone
au C2E
il faut que l'État avec le budget de
l'État et avec le contrôle parlementaire
qui va avec et c'est vrai que c'est ce
qu'il y a beaucoup manqué je trouve dans
le dans le contrôle de l'action de Lana
des C2E c'est d'avoir des parlementaires
qui décident et qui contrôlent il est
temps de reprendre la main et de montrer
que c'est une priorité importante et que
ça implique des coûts et des contrôles
merci beaucoup déjà à toutes et à tous
pour ces premières informations et je
laisse la parole à notre rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente merci à vous
tous oui déjà pour l'ensemble de ces de
ces explications
moi je voulais peut-être revenir sur sur
plusieurs points puis quelques questions
des questions globales après vous vous
répondrez en fonction de ce qui est de
ce qui peut vous intéresser
mais d'abord peut-être revenir sur un
point sur les quand on parle de
rénovation
énergétique c'est vrai qu'on peut avoir
deux aspects et c'est vrai que au cours
de ces différentes auditions on peut
avoir l'aspect
on va dire rejet de CO2 carbone et puis
on peut avoir et puis on a l'aspect
confort et puis donc coup derrière de de
du chauffage et puis toute cette
question de la précarité et que c'est
vrai que si on fait pas attention aux
deux on peut avoir par exemple on a des
exemples changer une chaudière fioul par
une une pompe à chaleur on va avoir une
action très forte effectivement sur le
Roger carbone on n'aura pas forcément
une action très intéressante à la fois
même en termes de confort même mon coût
oui on va baisser peut-être un petit peu
le coup mais on voit bien qu'à terme ça
sera pas ça sera pas suffisant donc
c'est vrai qu'il y a une vraie réflexion
en tout cas une vraie attention à avoir
sur la manière dont justement on peut on
peut intervenir et je le dis parce que
ça m'a un peu frappé tout à l'heure
juste par ça m'arrive de temps en temps
je tape France comme ça enfin 2023 quand
on fait ça ben la première page sur
lequel on tombe c'est avec un site qui
ressemble beaucoup à celui de l'État
avec le logo d'ailleurs de l'État et
c'est de changer sa sa chaudière et
passer avec une pompe à chaleur et en
fait c'est tout simplement une
entreprise quoi mais c'est vraiment le
premier le premier aspect qui nous
arrive et c'est vrai que les gens qui
vont se lancer dans cette démarche là
peuvent directement aller vers ça et
puis au bout du compte on n'aura pas
réglé en tout cas les problèmes on aura
certainement pas en tout cas régler
leurs problèmes de de précarité donc
c'est vrai que enfin voilà c'était juste
une remarque en tout cas par rapport à
ce que est-ce que vous disiez j'avais
une question peut-être sur Stop
exclusion énergétique là parce que vous
avez vous aviez parlé
vous faites la différence entre
précarité exclusion énergétique donc
c'était savoir si vous pouviez justement
préciser en tout cas comment vous va je
vous laisse répondre après c'était mais
sur cette sur cet aspect là sur comment
voilà quelle différence justement vous
faisiez d'appréciation entre précarité
exclusion énergétique parce que ça me
paraissait important et puis ensuite
j'ai des questions sur ça a été un petit
peu abordé à la fin sur l'impact sur la
santé en tout cas de ces logements alors
qui est lié aussi à la fois à la
rénovation thermique mais aussi à des
logements à des logements indignes
effectivement sur lequel il faut qu'on
travaille mais du coup sur cet impact
sur la santé est-ce que notamment sur
l'observatoire vous avez fait des des
vous avez des études vous avez des des
éléments de recherche sur cet impact sur
la santé même en termes de coût parce
que ça a été dit aussi c'est vrai que si
on intègre ce coup sur la sur la santé
et ses coût de santé derrière de vivre
dans un logement qui soit à la fois à la
fois indigne à fois mal chauffé ben ça
c'est c'est je pense du côté de grand
public en tout cas c'est un élément qui
peut être particulièrement intéressant
donc je voulais savoir si du coup vous
aviez fait enfin vous aviez des éléments
que vous pouviez nous apporter
j'avais un autre peut-être un autre
élément c'est vrai que ça a été abordé
par chacun d'entre vous en fait sur ce
qu'il faudrait faire quoi et sur le
dispositif qu'on a ma prime rénoff
France rénov l'accompagnateur Renov sur
lequel on attend beaucoup et c'est vrai
que vous avez tous dit qu'il faut une
politique plus un peu riz annuelle et
qu'il faut de la visibilité
définissements à long terme je crois
quasi tout le monde nous l'a dit donc on
a là-dessus je pense qu'il y a un vrai
partage sur le fait qu'on a besoin en
tout cas de cette visibilité on va dire
sur les outils qui existent tels qu'ils
sont actuellement
déjà est-ce que ce qui vous semble en
tout cas à modifier peut-être mais
adapté en tout cas par rapport justement
à avoir une action très forte et très
rapide sur de la rénovation sur de la
rénovation globale en clair c'est vrai
qu'on peut se poser des questions sur le
fait de dire est-ce que c'est ce
dispositif là qu'il faut améliorer et
puis essayer de mettre un peu plus de
subventions d'un côté est-ce que il faut
travailler sur le reste à charge ou
est-ce que c'est peut-être ce système là
tel qu'il est avec un système de
subvention qui est peut-être totalement
à revoir et peut-être à réimaginer quoi
enfin voilà ce que et du coup est-ce que
vous avez des réflexions par rapport à
par rapport à ça
et puis et puis dernière question après
mes collègues si aussi en termes de
d'expérience ou de retour et notamment
sur sur l'Observatoire sur le les
différences de précarité qu'on peut
avoir en fonction des territoires
que ça soit justement urbain ruraux
périurbain etc est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on
peut avoir des des différences en tout
cas sur ces territoires et à l'inverse
aussi sur
là où on a des expériences intéressantes
et est-ce que ça peut être lié aussi
justement à ce que on a plus
de choses intéressantes notamment en
matière d'accompagnement sur de la
grande péricarité en zone urbaine ou
plutôt justement en zone en zone rurale
enfin je veux dire est-ce qu'on a ce
qu'on a des éléments de ce type
de ce type là et puis il y a une
dernière question vous avez parlé de
d'auto réhabilitation je trouvais que
c'était aussi un aspect qui est assez
qui est assez intéressant qu'on peut
voir en tout cas
qui peut qui peut répondre qui répondra
pas à tout en tout cas qui peut répondre
à certains éléments mais je voulais
savoir si vous aviez en tout cas un
retour ou une expérience sur des
justement des problématiques à la fois
peut-être d'accompagnement à la fois en
termes de normes à la fois en termes de
on sait par exemple que c'est pas
évident de toucher toutes les aides
quand on est justement en
auto-rénovation voilà si vous aviez ces
retours merci
après je vous laisse alors qui commence
à toutes ces questions
c'est vrai donc
bonjour et merci de cette audition donc
oui je voulais vous rebondir sur deux de
vos questions la première tout d'abord
la question qu'on peut aborder
effectivement la rénovation énergétique
sous deux aspects la première uniquement
sur les aspects
économie carbone etc un aspect vraiment
uniquement bâti et le second sur
l'aspect confort
amélioration globale du bâtiment en fait
clairement il faut conjuguer ces deux
approches enfin nous au niveau du
mouvement Solia on est dans le cadre
d'une rénovation enfin d'une approche
globale de l'habitat et dans et on prône
justement cette rénovation globale alors
après il y a un enjeu pour aussi qu'on
soit plus efficace de s'accorder sur les
termes que l'on donne entre rénovation
globale rénovation performante etc pour
qu'on puisse bien partager tous les
objectifs mais en tout cas c'est vrai
que nous on prône cette approche là et
on peut se dire aussi que les grands
enjeux des
législative entre 2019 et 2021 c'est
quand même aussi la reprise du pilotage
du Sart par la main et parce que ces
deux approches sont aussi portées par
deux agences nationales que sont la dame
et Lama et par après sur le terrain
aussi différents acteurs
qui devraient fonctionner sous un mode
de synergie c'est vers cela qu'on
souhaite tendre et faire cela qu'il
faudrait tendre mais qui concrètement
sur le territoire on peut constater
plutôt de la concurrence alors là vous
allez nous dire vous êtes un peu jugé
party effectivement mais en tout cas
c'est vrai que cet enjeu de construction
d'une synergie territoriale pour appeler
tous ensemble vers le même objectif ça
c'est on va dire l'enjeu d'aujourd'hui
et l'enjeu justement de mon
accompagnateur rénov donc concernant la
mise en oeuvre de mon accompagnateur
Renov on accompagne à tort en off c'est
demain c'est le premier septembre donc
actuellement déjà nous on a un vrai
sujet sur comment on peut ne pas avoir
de rupture d'accompagnement entre le
modèle actuel et celui du 1er septembre
sachant que on a su la semaine dernière
qu'on la dispositif enfin qui permettait
l'agrément elle est vraiment être lancée
là à la fin du mois mais on avait encore
des incertitudes on ne sait pas encore
notre montant enfin le montant qui va
être d'évoluer à l'accompagnement et ce
qui n'empêche enfin ce qui ne permet pas
non plus de construire une synergie
territoriale avec notamment
l'implication des collectivités sur ce
sur ce dispositif
donc est-ce que c'est un bon dispositif
nous dans tous les cas on avait et c'est
des éléments sur laquelle on avait fait
part dans le cadre de la commission
sociale on croit au rôle de l'assistance
à maîtrise d'ouvrage dans un concept de
conseil neutre de conseils techniques on
va dire objectif qui va correspondre qui
va pouvoir relever du coup quels sont
les enjeux sur le bâti et qui va aussi
pouvoir donner un conseil aux ménage sur
ses possibilités en fonction de sa
situation financière
nous à sollia nous sommes spécialisés
sur on va dire ce qu'on appelle les
publicanas donc c'est les ménages des
quatre premiers des cils qu'on appelle
aussi les publics modestes et très
modestes donc on a aussi à coeur que ces
publics puissent avoir un conseil
financier réellement adapté à leur
situation afin qu'ils ne passent pas à
côté d'aide ou dispositif de solvabilité
en cas il aurait droit en fait et c'est
vrai que pour ces pour ces ménages là
comme le soulignait ma directrice il y a
un vrai enjeu que dès les premiers
conseils on puisse leur donner cet enjeu
d'accompagnement enfin de d'aller vers
de la performance globale parce que s'il
commence à faire un premier geste déjà
ça peut grever leur capacités de
financement ensuite ce premier geste
peut ne pas du tout être en cohérence
avec
les autres
compléments de travaux qui devront être
faits pour arriver à la rénovation
performante parce que même s'il est
possible de faire une rénovation
performante par geste ça je m'appuie là
dessus sur l'étude de l'ADEME qui le
montre on ne peut pas multiplier plus de
2 3 gestes maximum et en plus c'est
ça doit être anticipé en fait qu'on est
dans de la rénovation globale par geste
pour ne pas que derrière on est des
gestes qui soient incohérents les uns
avec les autres donc
en tout cas sur la question du
futur dispositif donc mon accompagnateur
en off qui arrive quand même maintenant
donc sur le principe nous nous avons
porté cet enjeu d'accompagnement neutre
de A à Z des ménages avec un
accompagnement aussi administratif
jusqu'au paiement des factures donc
clairement on s'y retrouve
lors de la présentation du décret au CNH
on avait émis par contre de fortes
réserves sur l'implication et l'agrément
des entreprises privées justement sur ce
critère de neutralité c'est-à-dire ne
pas être juge et parti par rapport à un
équipement qu'on m'a proposé ne pas être
jugé parti par rapport à une solution ou
à des entreprises et ça c'est ce qui
nous semble très important à
avoir et là-dessus je rejoins tout à
fait ce que Manuel d'Homère a dit tout à
l'heure sur les enjeux d'avoir des
instruments de contrôle et aussi le
contrôle parlementaire sur ce dispositif
qui va être mis en oeuvre parce que
clairement actuellement on a un
changement d'échelle on a plus de moyens
financiers qu'on n'a jamais eu la
question c'est comment on les dépenses
bien et on les dépense pour une
véritable performance énergétique
derrière et un véritable on va dire une
véritable transition
écologique en fait du parc de logement
donc après plusieurs je vais je vais
m'arrêter là mais on peut quand même
avoir plusieurs enjeux en fait sur
comment réussir justement la
transition énergétique via mon
accompagnateur rénov parce que
clairement le volume d'accompagnement
est tel que c'est un défi collectif où
chacun doit prendre sa part donc il y a
un enjeu de pouvoir c'est pour ça que
j'insistais tout à l'heure sur la
question des synergies donc on va dire
que déjà il y aura un premier enjeu qui
est comment on peut optimiser localement
le système existant en générant des
synergies entre les acteurs qui savent
déjà faire et qui peuvent déjà faire
ensuite
et ça c'est en matière c'est
organisation du système d'acteur ne peut
être fait que localement en fait c'est à
dire que c'est vraiment localement que
les collectivités territoriales peuvent
organiser le système d'acteurs
permettent de faire monter en
compétences certains acteurs etc ensuite
ça implique aussi de travailler sur le
développement des compétences avec la
question la formation etc et ça c'est
vrai que le fait pouvoir voir une vision
plus réelle des crédits de la nappe
permettrait à l'ensemble de la chaîne de
production de se projeter en fait sur le
volume de personnes qui devront qui
seront nécessaires pour accompagner ces
ménages
et enfin nous au niveau de mon
accompagnateur rénov
pour nous
il y a un véritable enjeu à se souvenir
que on est au croisement justement entre
des enjeux de d'intervention sur le parc
et de transition écologique globale du
parc mais et des politiques sociales et
des politiques locales de l'habitat et
c'est pour ça que c'est nécessaire que
notamment sur les ménages modestes et
très modestes enfin il faut permettre
d'avoir un parcours usagé qui soit
lisible et qui soit pas une usine à gaz
et un parcours usagé avec des acteurs
dans lesquels les ménages aient
confiance donc pour nous ça nous semble
important dans le cas de mon
accompagnateur rénov de pouvoir
commencer à construire cette synergie
territoriale et cette organisation
territoriale qu'actuellement est en
suspens en fait aussi de l'absence des
arbitrages
et en tout cas
il nous semble nécessaire voilà de
définir des parcours fléchés on va dire
entre certains types de ménages et
certains accompagnateurs aux compétences
reconnues aussi pour que les ménages
modestes et très modestes soient dès le
démarrage en fait accompagné par des
accompagnateurs qui ont possèdent les
compétences
je vais m'arrêter là
alors qui veut aller loin
oui merci alors effectivement pour
rebondir sur la question de la santé qui
qui nous importe et que Véronique et
zerati qui était médecin à EDF a
beaucoup d'autres à beaucoup travaillé
avec avec les Anglais
effectivement il est désormais très
clair que
la
rénovation de des passoires thermiques
permettrait des d'éviter des coups de
santé et selon une étude d'ailleurs sur
le CGDD qui est paru en 2022
la rénovation de d'ici 2028 permettrait
d'éviter 10 milliards d'euros par an de
coût de santé donc ça c'est vrai que
c'est un chiffre assez vertigineux et on
suit actuellement une étude qui
s'appelle
Renov santé
qui est notamment menée par un certain
nombre d'acteurs dont d'ailleurs Solia
et puis le test etc qui vont vous
permettre d'identifier les dépenses de
santé avant travaux et après travaux de
façon effectivement à identifier les
gains que cela peut générer sur des
dépenses santé ce qui est un véritable
argument pour effectivement renforcer
les aides à la rénovation qui dont les
montants sont à notre sens pas pas
suffisant
voilà cette étude est en cours et on
aura des résultats
en fin 2024 voilà c'est c'est une très
grosse étude sur vous avez le nom de
logements concernés passés voilà on vous
donnera toute façon toutes les
références évidemment
moi je voulais juste peut-être porter
votre attention sur la précarité
énergétique comme un sujet un peu
différent on a rénovation énergétique
même si évidemment c'est c'est les deux
sujets se réunissent et en tout cas
autour de la rénovation du logement on
c'est un levier pour sortir les ménages
d'après cette énergétiques
selon donc les dernières statistiques on
attend l'enquête nationale de logement
mais donc selon la dernière il y avait
il y avait 50 neuf pour cent des ménages
en 4 énergétique qui était locataire
d'où
notre préoccupation de
peut-être de réfléchir sur les aides aux
propriétaires bailleurs
alors on entend effectivement je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec Manuel
d'Homère sur
la situation plutôt favorable de la
plupart des propriétaires bailleurs il
n'empêche que effectivement sur une
frange non négligeable alors je sais pas
manuel je parlais de 10 à 15%
il y a sûrement
là une nécessité de revoir le montant de
l'aide accordée quand on regarde
précisément
les aides qui concernent les
propriétaires bailleurs actuellement
sur sur les 650 sur les 605 6669
dossiers financés par ma prime rénove il
y a seulement 2 % qui concernent les
propriétaires d'ailleurs
et l'aide et la détente moyenne de 3841
euros donc effectivement quand on voit
le montant et on en a parlé de d'un
chantier de rénovation
et le montant d'un chantier de
rénovation globale performante a été
évaluée par l'EDEM à 80000 euros on
comprend bien la difficulté
à rénover ces logements et
l'importance
de retravailler de revoir le montant du
du reste à charge alors c'est vrai qu'on
avait tendance nous à l'ADEME à dire
qu'à partir du moment où il y avait une
exigence de performance énergétique
requises il fallait que le reste à
charge pour les très modestes soit prise
en charge par les pouvoirs publics de
façon à ce qu'on puisse atteindre ces
objectifs ambitieux
sinon effectivement on risque et ça a
déjà été dit de
d'empiler de des gestes qui sont parfois
contraires et en tout cas qui vont pas
forcément vers une vers des objectifs de
performance énergétique
voilà ce que je souhaitais dire sur
geodip vous aviez posé un certain nombre
de questions alors permettez-moi d'en
dire quelques mots
car actuellement cet outil de
géolocalisation qui a été mise en oeuvre
par l'obser international propriétaire
énergétique qui permet un repérage des
ménages en précarité énergétique
du lieu de leurs dépenses liées à
l'habitat mais aussi à leur mobilité à
une maille iris c'est un outil très
performant qui permet à de nombreuses
collectivités territoriales de faire un
prédiagnostic de la précarité
énergétique actuellement on cherche des
financements complémentaires pour le
confier à nos partenaires qui s'appelle
le rare le réseau des agences régionales
de l'énergie de façon à pouvoir
mobiliser notre ingénieur mobilité sur
la question de la mobilité qui est assez
peu explorée
actuellement à l'onpe puisqu'on a
beaucoup focalisé sur cet outil donc
voilà il est en devenir il va être
réactualisé puisque on attend comme je
vous l'ai dit les données de l'Enquête
nationale logement 2020 on a déjà les
données de l'Enquête nationale
mobilité transport à intégrer donc c'est
un outil qui est très puissant mais pour
le le confier à cette opérateur il va
nous falloir donc des financements
complémentaires de la part des
partenaires donc voilà ça c'est ça
c'était simplement donc aujourd'hui il y
a pas beaucoup de collectivités qui s'en
sont saisis si quand même aujourd'hui il
est au maximum de ce qu'on peut c'est à
dire qu'en fait on le livre
usagers
de façon simultanée c'est vraiment la
capacité maximale et on renouvelle tous
les trois mois les connexions et donc
selon Pierre Taillan le l'ingénieur
mobilité il a pour l'instant été
proposé à plus de 1500 collectivités
territoriales d'accord est-ce que ce
sont des collectivités je présume de
taille différente dans des territoires
plus ou moins frappés plus ou moins
fortement par la précarité énergétique
ou est-ce qu'il y a une analyse plus
fine alors il y a une analyse qui a été
qui a été menée par le rappel le réseau
des agences le rappel pardon le réseau
des acteurs de la pauvreté de la
précarité énergétique dans le logement
et on a donc un certain nombre de retour
sur l'usage de l'outil qui permet non
seulement un partage d'un état des lieux
avec entre techniciens et élu pour
justement mobiliser des financements sur
des territoires particuliers ça permet
d'évaluer aussi l'impact du
et de la modification du territoire du
slim ça permet une connaissance donc
très fine du territoire le slim c'est le
service
local d'intervention maîtrise de
l'énergie voilà qui a été financé donc
qui est porté par Leclerc et qui permet
d'assurer le repérage vous le connaissez
c'est pour ça c'est une petite d'accord
vous me testez mais je peux vous en
parler
non non le slim c'est effectivement un
outil en devenir évidemment qui qui nous
semble extrêmement intéressant donc tout
ça pour dire que justement il faut
équiper ce type d'acteur pour bien
identifier les zones qui sont qui sont
qui sont en situation de poker
énergétique et mobiliser des acteurs sur
ces sur ces territoires là donc voilà
geodips et c'est un outil en devenir
qu'on souhaite qu'on souhaite développer
avec des nouveaux partenariats
financiers
voilà pour pour donc voilà elle reste à
charge nulle
si on vise une rénovation non mais c'est
à condition effectivement de viser au
plus haut mais parce que sinon on n'y
arrivera pas
et puis effectivement ne pas oublier les
locataires parce que la rénovation elle
centre elle est très axée sur les
propriétaires or c'est une partie plutôt
moins importante que que les locataires
qui qui sont concernés
je laisse la parole alors qui cote soit
intervenir par rapport à des questions
du rapporteur auquel il aurait pas été
apportée de réponse ou d'autres
interventions et puis si à mes collègues
qui souhaitent intervenir qui nous
fascine j'ai juste un mot pardon sur les
sur la santé on avait mené une étude
avec Pierre Madec économiste à l'OSCE
qui avait montré que toutes choses
égales par ailleurs donc à condition
sociale familiale équivalente des
personnes qui vivaient dans des
logements difficiles à chauffer avec 50%
de risque supplémentaires de se déclarer
en mauvaise santé donc on voit que c'est
un déterminant de santé absolument
majeur c'est la même chose pour le bruit
ou d'autres d'autres désordres dans le
logement on avait chiffré également dans
une étude il y a une dizaine d'années
sur la comparaison entre des ménages en
passant énergétique et d'autres ménages
à 800 millions d'euros les dépenses de
soins économisés par an si les passeurs
énergétiques étaient éradiqués et puis
d'autres d'autres évaluations ont été
faites plus récemment notamment pour le
ministère de la transition écologique
qui about des chiffres plus importants
parce qu'il prenaient en compte le prix
de la vie et les morts évités et donc en
économie les morts évités je crois que
c'est autour de 2 à 3 millions d'euros
par personne par décès à éviter donc
évidemment ça fait gonfler très
fortement les bénéfices quand on les
monétise avec toute la brutalité qui est
derrière mais pour pour la nation et
c'est vrai qu'on peut pas attendre enfin
autant on peut investir les gains de
performance énergétique les économies
d'énergie autant la santé qu'on va
préserver ou la mort qu'on va éviter ne
se monétise pas dans la vraie vie elle
se monétise pour des économistes et donc
là il y a un intérêt vraiment à ce que
la collectivité intervienne pour éviter
ces pathologies et ses décès prématurés
juste pour compléter d'abord sur la
partie santé pour soulever quand même
effectivement qu'on manque de chiffres
on aimerait bien évaluer un peu plus et
je partage la même le même ressenti que
Manuel sur la question de la brutalité
de mettre des montants par rapport à des
vies et l'étude de France stratégie
l'année dernière je crois la développer
mais il y a un point particulier c'est
comment d'expert santé environnement je
crois qu'il y en a une centaine en
France et on en a quelques-uns parfois
sur certains territoires et je crois
qu'à chaque fois ça nous aide aussi à
comprendre ce qui se passe et à faire le
lien parce qu'évidemment le lien avec
les autorités de santé est toujours
important pour répondre à votre question
très précise sur la différence entre
précarité énergétique et exclusion
énergétique c'est pour nous ce qui
définit le besoin d'accompagnement
c'est-à-dire que vous avez des gens qui
peuvent s'en sortir tout seul non on
considère que tout ça fait partie de la
précarité énergétique il y a des gens
qui peuvent pas voilà c'est pour ça que
nous on recommande cette mission
d'ensemble y est solidaires quel que
soit la terminologie il y en a c'est que
un accompagnement ça prend du temps
d'abord faut créer l'esclimat de
confiance faut faire le projet avec la
famille il y a tout un ensemble d'étapes
et qui fait qu'il faut tenir la main et
c'est de l'accompagnement humain c'est
de la compétence humaine on a fait une
étude l'année dernière avec un cabinet
qui s'appelle co pour voir qu'est-ce
qu'il existait en terme de formation sur
l'accompagnement social parce qu'il y a
trois dimensions il y a l'accompagnement
d'ingénierie financière l'accompagnement
social et l'accompagnement technique et
il existe malheureusement très peu de
choses à la formation à l'accompagnement
social en France et ça manque
effectivement nous donc on va on va
multiplier les formations on s'est
rapproché pour ça de la fac et rentrer
dans notre association pas mal d'acteurs
parce que va falloir former massivement
en effet une
dans les chiffres mais une étude avec un
cabinet en pro-bonos l'année dernière
qui s'appelle l'évé Wyman on a on a
calculé un peu ces 500 000 propriétaires
occupants qui vivent dans les passoires
thermiques et qui sont à moins de 10
euros par jour et par personne combien
de personnes il faut pour les
accompagner on a calculé qu'il en
fallait 11000 voilà donc voilà vous
voyez les étapes mais encore une fois le
dispositif m'en accompagnateur est œuvre
renforcé peut être le dispositif
financier qui permet réellement de
financer cet accompagnement sans lequel
il y aura pas de rénovation massive chez
les grands précaires ça nous on nous en
sommes totalement convaincus et ça ça
répond évidemment bien sûr aux questions
de long terme sur l'auto réhabilitation
accompagnée alors je suis pas un expert
du sujet Les Compagnons Bâtisseurs et
d'autres
font des missions de ce genre c'est la
spécialité des Compagnons Bâtisseurs je
pense ça devrait peut-être la peine que
vous les puissiez les entendre parce que
voilà il y a des vrais problèmes
techniques juridiques enfin on est sur
des métiers très différents de
l'accompagnement classique dans le
bâtiment ça il y a des problèmes de
responsabilité de décennale enfin je
vais je veux pas parler en leur nom mais
il y a des vrais problèmes techniques
très très pointus
ce qui est aussi très intéressant dans
le travail qui mène actuellement c'est
le confort d'été on en a pas beaucoup
parlé mais effectivement c'est un
problème majeur heureusement je dirais
des entreprises fournisseurs
d'électricité ont décidé de plus couper
les compteurs faut quand même rappeler
qu'en période de canicule même un frigo
même à 1 kW en souvenez des vies
l'été c'est important de aussi de
protéger cette dimension là et que les
Compagnons Bâtisseurs travaillent
beaucoup sur l'ultramarin nous on
commence tout doucement on a financé
pour l'instant deux ou trois maisons
mais c'est totalement différent de
travailler à la Guyane la Réunion etc
évidemment pour les questions d'été
hiver se jouent extrêmement différemment
alors après sur les rénovations globales
performantes on en est tous convaincus
qu'il faut vraiment tendre vers ces
rénovations globale performante même
s'il faut pas complètement abandonner
les rénovations par gestes parce
qu'elles sont quand même voilà la
première étape et le premier levier se
pose aussi la problème le problème quand
on met en œuvre des rénovations globales
performantes c'est soit on peut les
faire en site occupé soit c'est
extrêmement compliqué voire impossible
de faire ce type de rénovation ensuite
occupé est-ce que vous de votre côté
vous avez été confronté à ça vous avez
réfléchi à ces deux possibilités parce
que il y a des moments où c'est
compliqué enfin moi qui a été présidente
d'un office publique de l'habitat
pendant plus de 10 ans même quand on
montait des opérations de réhabilitation
sans parler encore de véritablement
rénovation énergétique avec des
opérations qu'on pouvait pas mener en
site occupé donc après la question du
relogement de ces personnes enfin est-ce
que là-dessus vous avez une vision des
choses et comment est-ce qu'on pourrait
aussi mieux adapter enfin mieux outiller
tout cela quoi alors on est pour
l'instant sur quelque chose de très
expérimental on a plusieurs pistes sur
lequel on travaille mais pour lequel on
peut pas vous proposer des mesures
majeures aujourd'hui en dehors
évidemment de financement de fiscalité
et autres
on discute avec différents organisations
qui ont des parcs je pense à la fac
notamment évidemment qui a un gros parc
à rénover sur lequel évidemment
travailler on travaille avec eux des
grandes compagnies hôtelières qui
seraient prêtes à nous mettre à
disposition et que je dis serait on est
je pense que ça va se faire on est prêt
et autrement on travaille avec des
fabricants de Tiny House pour pouvoir
apporter du logement en toute proximité
enfin pardon dans une autre époque on
appellerait ça des bungalows mais
derrière
notamment dans la métropole de Lille on
les avait primés dans notre effet une
année
la fabrique des tiny house qu'ils
amortissent pour le tourisme et quand
elles sont amorties ils mettent à
disposition de l'associations pour la
précarité énergétique mais on n'est pas
sur des ressorts de massification comme
vous le disiez tout à l'heure on est
encore sur l'expérimentation
l'aspect le plus probablement le plus
simple mais ça pose encore les problèmes
techniques peut-être si on pouvait
envisager
du mécénat de locaux enfin nous on est
logé par une entreprise qui défiscalise
mais je sais pas organiser une
défiscalisation avec un hôtel qui nous
prêterait des chambres peut-être qu'il y
a quelque chose à creuser à creuser de
ce niveau là notamment sur des périodes
certaines régions etc il y a sûrement
des choses à inventer mais
on n'est pas encore tout à fait mûr sur
le sujet ça fait partie des sujets qu'on
travaillera sur les prochaines versions
du scénario comme les questions de santé
évidemment
vous intervenir
si je puis me permettre donc sur cette
question là clairement on se rapproche
des enjeux de la lutte contre l'habitant
indigne et du coup aussi des outils de
la lutte contre l'habitat en ligne et
c'est vrai que ça cette question de ce
qu'on appelle les logements tiroirs en
fait qui permettent d'héberger en fait
les ménages pendant les travaux ça c'est
aussi enfin c'est un
c'est quelque chose dont on a beaucoup
parlé dans le cas de la lutte contre
l'habitat indigne il y a eu aussi un des
travaux en fait avec l'Union sociale
pour l'habitat sur comment on pouvait
mieux mobiliser du coin parc de logement
pour des opérations programmées par
exemple dans le cadre de copropriété et
c'est vrai que déjà pour la lutte contre
l'habitat indigne on a du mal à le faire
sur les enjeux de précarité énergétique
c'est la même chose c'est à dire que bon
déjà c'est pas identifié comme un axe de
réservation potentiel
dans le cadre des parc de logement
éventuellement disponible ensuite
clairement ça peut se faire mais c'est
vrai qu'en général c'est un peu au cas
par cas on mobilise des solutions
familiales on peut mobiliser aussi les
collectivités qui peuvent avoir des
logements tiroirs et on arrive sur
certains chantiers ambitieux mais c'est
beaucoup de on va dire de négociations
en fait au cas par cas a quand même
pouvoir reloger le ménage pendant la
durée des travaux ou alors faire des
échanges de pièces mais c'est vrai que
ça complexifie beaucoup en fait les
rénovations mais par contre ça cette
question de pouvoir travailler sur des
logements site occupés notamment dans le
cas du parc locatif c'est quand même
très important en fait c'est à dire que
ou alors soit on se dit que les
rénovations se font uniquement à la
relocation mais dans ces cas-là ça veut
dire il faut vraiment qu'il y ait une
vigilance très forte pour ne pas rater
cette occasion en fait qui du coup peut
ne pas se représenter ou alors ça
implique de se donner les moyens
de développer des solutions de logements
de tiroir pour pouvoir travailler en
site occupé mais c'est un vrai sujet
d'autres questions
je le rapporteur non ça va
moi j'aurais voulu savoir sur les vous
avez parlé de créer un C2E spécifique
justement on peut les personnes en
situation de précarité énergétique ce
que vous pouvez un petit peu nous le
développer
alors actuellement on a on est un des
lauréats enfin on est L'Oréal d'un des
projets
d'économie d'énergie qui vont nous
permettre de créer des territoires zéro
exclusion énergétiques pour nous c'est
le son des démonstrateurs tout
simplement de toute la démarche qui est
dans le scénario avec une un objectif de
14 territoires
3000 accompagnements sur trois ans
la période de démonstrateur sachant que
les scénages doivent permettre sur les
deux années suivantes d'aller sans
territoire et ensuite évidemment
d'accélérer pour envisager une
éradication à 2030
pour cela effectivement il y a une
nécessité d'élargir si
les C2 heures continue à être un moyen
de financement
il y a un moment donné on va on n'est
pas à l'échelle on est à l'échelle de la
démonstrateur
mais pas une démarche globale
d'accompagnement des
je parle pardon que des 500 000
propriétaires occupants évidemment qui
sont une partie de la difficulté il y a
aussi les locataires mais il faut pas
sous-estimer les propriétaires occupants
ils sont plus de 500 000 familles ça
fait quand même un million
200 je sais plus combien pardon on doit
compter 2,6 par par foyer parce que pour
juste pour compléter parce que pour
revenir sur ce que la différence entre
précarité et ce énergétique c'est que
les sujets énergétique implique
énormément d'autres problèmes notamment
des problèmes de santé des problèmes
d'handicap c'est aussi pour ça qu'il y a
besoin d'une technicité parce que un
ensemble biais solidaire dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure il doit pas
seulement être compétent pour monter une
primana c'est 10 ou 12 dossiers il y a
une expertise en plus quand c'est du
handicap et y compris et heureusement
quand d'être capable d'aller voir la
Fondation Abbé Pierre ou notre petit
fonds pour pouvoir boucler des
financements et donc ça demande une des
fortes très fortes technicité
parce que tout ça est très compliqué et
un moment je pense que l'enjeu est quand
même enfin
sur beaucoup d'enjeux environnementaux
notamment quand je précise le comité
français pour l'époqueurs mais enfin de
croisement sociaux et environnementaux
c'est la première fois qu'on a un enjeu
aussi gagnant-gagnant gagnant quoi qui
intègre la santé et il y a pas une seule
seconde où on se pose la question quand
on croit fait progresser les choses et
ce qu'on gagne pas aussi pour le climat
quand on quand on aide une famille parce
que il y a quand même aussi une
injustice sociale c'est que on l'a on
commence à l'entendre dans des familles
quand on prend un peu le temps c'est le
sentiment des gens pas de pas contribuer
à l'effort collectif oui évidemment la
fin du mois est prioritaire par rapport
à la situation de la planète qu'on en a
pas de quoi se nourrir mais mais quand
le gamin il rentre de l'école et qu'il a
eu un cours de développement durable il
trouve que c'est pas c'est pas bien que
ses parents ils ont une vieille
chaudière à pétrole un diesel pourri et
qui mange je sais pas quoi donc il y a
aussi la justice sociale
profonde à agir sur ces sujets de la
précarité énergétique et dans un climat
d'augmentation des difficultés parce que
faut évidemment
personne peut dire qu'on va stabiliser
du coup l'énergie en France
d'autant que coût de l'énergie c'est
enfin le placoplatre après 15% l'année
dernière je le métal tout ce qui va avec
une question une question complémentaire
ce que c'est vrai qu'on va avoir je
crois demain ou après-demain une plutôt
une table ronde sur la question des
fraudes des arnaques et enfin voilà tout
ce qui peut être autour de de ma prime
rénove et donc voilà juste avoir si sur
cet aspect là et non peut-être pas
notamment sur l'observatoire mais
peut-être que vous avez aussi des
retours
parce que c'est vrai que moi j'ai pu
voir pas mal de
soit fraude soit soit arnaque soit en
fait des personnes qui rentrent dans le
dispositif et puis qui s'y prennent mal
et qui du coup remplissent pas forcément
très bien le le dossier ensuite
l'incapacité de pour pouvoir revenir en
arrière mais du coup alors là avec une
précarité encore plus forte parce que
des gens qui s'étaient lancés en se
disant je vais obtenir la
une subvention pour le changement de ma
chaudière ou pour voilà qui se retrouve
ne pas toucher justement leurs prix mais
à se retrouver dans une situation encore
pire que celle qu'ils étaient qui
étaient avant surtout qu'en général en
même temps comme il y a pas eu
d'accompagnement ils ont pas forcément
fait le bon choix
énergétique ou voilà donc voilà c'est ce
que vous avez des retours en tout cas
est-ce que c'est des éléments que vous
pouvez vous avez pu voir
alors donc l'une des missions de l'ompe
c'est aussi une mener des enquêtes
sociologiques auprès des ménages et donc
on a un certain nombre de retours sur
effectivement
notamment ses chantiers d'isolation à
l'euro
dont une partie a pas forcément trouver
satisfaction et en fait surtout la
difficulté que font valoir les
travailleurs sociaux c'est qu'une fois
qu'un ménage s'est fait rouler dans la
farine
après il y a une très grande difficulté
de retrouver une relation de confiance
et surtout de l'emmener sur un parcours
d'accompagnement vers des travaux donc
ça c'est vrai que c'est une difficulté
extrêmement difficile et
ce qui est également important de noter
alors vous parliez effectivement de
d'accompagnement c'est que
et c'est sans doute par faute
d'accompagnement que le ménage est
accepte ou se lance dans dans des
chantiers parce qu'il est extrêmement
sollicité il y a vraiment une sur
sollicitation de déménage qui sont en
plus assez souvent présents en leur
domicile
et donc nous on plaide beaucoup pour un
accompagnement avec un seul référent
parce que ça c'est aussi un des
enseignements que l'enquête ont j'étudie
mal que nous avons mené nous a nous
apporter c'est la la multiplicité des
interlocuteurs qui est extrêmement
complexe pour une personne en difficulté
et qui finit par lâcher en fait
le projet de travaux parce qu'il a plus
la même personne alors en plus c'est
vrai que l'enquête on l'a mené au moment
de la période de la crise sanitaire donc
c'est extrêmement complexe puisqu'il y
avait des arrêts de travail etc
mais là encore on voit bien que une fois
que la personne est plus en relation de
confiance elle disparaît voilà donc d'où
l'importance de ce parcours dans la avec
un seul référent qui puisse suivre
l'ensemble de du du dossier du premier
diagnostic jusqu'à finalement le
contrôle des travaux voilà ça c'est ça
c'est le parcours idéal quoi voilà et ça
effectivement ça aide lui vitrait de
d'avoir à faire à des à des marchands de
de
simples vitrage vendu triple vitrage
enfin voilà donc voilà c'est des plutôt
des retours qualitatifs
peut-être pour aussi vice vous nous avez
parlé d'un outil de la création d'une
banque qui serait dédiée à la rénovation
énergétique est-ce que vous pouvez un
peu plus nous nous détailler ce ce
projet ou cette idée donc on fait le
constat que jusqu'à présent les acteurs
bancaires ne se sont pas
non pas trouvé de modèle encore une fois
c'est pas une critique du secteur
bancaire je constate juste qu'il y a pas
beaucoup de prédistribués
et donc on s'interroge du pourquoi et
quand il y a peut-être eu des tentatives
à un moment donné de confier qu'à une
seule banque avec un actionnariat
peut-être public important de le soin de
faire ou parce que c'était un réseau
mutualiste sauf que là c'est une sorte
très vite à des problématiques de
concurrence parce que pour une banque
son fichier c'est très puressieux et
donc si un de ses clients va ne
serait-ce que pour un prêt de quelques
milliers d'euros chez un concurrent
ça marche pas non plus donc on se
retrouve dans ce statu quo du
financement privé de la rénovation
énergétique et donc on se dit malgré
tout l'enjeu il est là social un des
humblesment on en est beaucoup parlé il
y a un enjeu qui n'intéresse pas au
premier chef cette commission mais quand
même moi je financier de positionnement
de Paris comme une place Verte au sein
de l'Union européenne etc donc comment
on essaye de jouer de tous ces éléments
et on se dit mais peut-être que si on
avait un véhicule unique dédié qui ne
soit pas public mais dans lequel
pourrait abonder éventuellement des
fonds publics
qui permettent donc aux banques de de
remplir leur
obligations de créance verte de même de
les valoriser
qui sache faire voilà du du
recouvrement et qui soit dédié
uniquement à la distribution de ce des
différents types
de produits qu'on a déjà évoqué
aujourd'hui que ça soit
enfin voilà il en existe déjà sur le sur
le sur le marché Copé des aides pas mais
autre
il nous semble que ça serait de nature à
répondre à un certain nombre de blocages
aujourd'hui constatés on pourrait
imaginer je sais pas il faudrait que que
l'État apporte sa garantie à cet
instrument là qu'il est peut-être un
droit de veto dans le conseil
d'administration d'un tel
consortium et
ça ça pourrait aussi rassurer les les
banques qui se posent très vite la
question de la garantie
voilà et le coût de la garantie pour
l'État mon avis on est n'est pas à ce
point-là considérable
qui n'y trouverait pas un intérêt
politique et social très très fort
voilà c'est moins cher que du bien
d'autres dispositifs publics qui
aujourd'hui n'ont voilà n'ont pas fait
leur complètement leur preuve
voilà donc c'est une réflexion qu'on est
savait si ça existe ailleurs dans
d'autres pays ou pas non on n'a pas
encore fait ce benchmark on va s'y
employer nous on en a parlé à quelques
acteurs plutôt de manière un peu
confidentielle donc là je le fais d'une
manière plus publique c'est bien reçu il
nous reste à quand même une étape
importante c'est d'en parler aux banques
elle-même qui serait quand même les
premiers concernés mais du côté de la
sphère état entendue au sens très large
on a eu plusieurs endroits des des
accueils très positifs autour de cette
idée voilà donc
[Musique]
disons que ça ça rejoint la question du
rapporteur de il existe des choses mais
comment on les améliore donc nous il
nous semble que c'est une étape
voilà une étape à franchir on voit qu'il
y a des financements mais qui trouve pas
leur cible qui trouve qui sont pas sur
les volumes attendus donc c'est
peut-être le véhicule adéquat et après
peut-être qu'on peut aussi améliorer
chacun des outils qui seraient
distribués encore une fois à nous sur le
PAM je pense qu'il faut l'ouvrir aux
propriétaires bailleurs parce qu'on
arrête pas la question des locataires si
on s'adresse pas aux propriétaires
d'ailleurs
il me semble que la question des
ressources n'est pas centrale parce que
surtout s'il y a une encore une fois on
s'adresse aux propriétaires bailleurs
finalement ce qui vivent le logement eux
on connaît pas leur situation sociale
peut-être qu'il faut conditionner les
deux on montre
il y a aussi la question de peut-être de
la prepinelle dans le cadre du CNR il y
a des discussions des propositions qui
sont faites sur le statut du bailleur
privé etc
bon le statut du meilleur privé il est
plutôt entendu dans le amortissement une
édiction d'impôts au moment de
l'accession mais peut-être que ça
pourrait embarquer aussi la les travaux
de rénovation on sera assez favorable
voilà il y a la question aussi des plans
purés annuels des travaux aujourd'hui
ces deux et demi pour cent des travaux
qui sont
financement est obligatoire par les
copropriétaires est-ce qu'il faut
augmenter un petit peu ce niveau là et
ce qui peut y avoir en Suisse de la
partie obligatoire une partie volontaire
et pour inciter à cette partie
volontaire mais il pourrait y avoir une
déduction fiscale sur les revenus
fonciers ou autres
voilà un petit peu quelques quelques
réflexions qu'on voulait partager
peut-être encore une dernière sur ces
outils qui peuvent t'améliorer nous sur
le DPE
parce que tout ce que vous dites sur la
tout à fait important sur la
sécurisation presque psychologique j'ai
envie de dire des
candidats à la rénovation énergétique
donc de ce point là France rénov etc
voilà il faut que ça se mette bien en
place mais le principe on le partage on
le comprend sur le DPE aussi il faut
qu'il
une intelligibilité de
la du fait qu'il faut qu'il soit
stabilisé techniquement etc pas
forcément revenir là-dessus mais
aujourd'hui c'est le dépe individuel est
opposable est-ce qu'il y a pas une
question sur le DPE collectif
là encore ça rejoint propose tout à
l'heure sur le fait que la copropriété à
notre sens doit être vu comme un
ensemble
et donc c'est pas parce que vous êtes au
milieu de l'immeuble que vous êtes
peut-être un peu moins concerné que vous
allez
enfin exploser différemment vous avez
pas voté les les travaux pourtant ces
travaux ils sont nécessaires dans un
bien dans une perspective de bien
collectif donc voilà c'est favorable au
début collectifs comme outil aussi de
sécurisation et de lisibilité
merci est-ce que l'un d'entre vous
aurait quelque chose à rajouter
non
il vous reste oui
sur les arnaques c'est vrai que c'est
beaucoup sur les gestes individuels le
passage à la rénovation globale avec
l'accompagnement par définition va
réduire fortement les arnaques et
peut-être avoir une une discussion
chemin sur ce rythme de passage des
gestes à la Reno globale un peu
impopulaire ce serait je pense qu'on est
cette
cette transition elle est difficile
parce que le président s'est engagé sur
700 000 rénovations donc là on est à 700
000 rénovations et qui sont pas des
frères rénovations et donc pour accepter
de passer assez rapidement des gestes
Reno global il faut je crois par
réalisme accepter de baisser un moment
en dessous de 700 000 le temps de cette
transition parce qu'on fera pas 700 000
renoglobal en 2024 on le sait bien et
donc accepter peut-être que il y aura
quelques années on sera à 400.500 000 et
pas à 700 000 mais que l'horizon c'est
d'arriver à 700 000 rénovations globale
et ça je pense que dans la politique du
chiffre telle qu'elle est menée
aujourd'hui c'est une une position qui
aurait du mal à être entendu alors qu'à
mon avis c'est une position assez
raisonnable
oui être plus réaliste en tout cas pour
pouvoir après monter en charge on voit
bien que ça sert à rien de de mettre des
objectifs très très ambitieux lorsqu'on
sait qu'on va pas réussir à les tenir il
y a rien de pire parce qu'en même temps
c'est vrai que ça ça décourage un petit
peu tout le monde et puis on voit bien
que les résultats ne sont pas là donc
voilà c'est
insatisfaisant au maximum quoi et
jusqu'à là les objectifs ils ont
toujours été très élevés mais une forte
ambition affichée mais ce qu'on a dit
est-ce que qui est aussi pourquoi de
cette commission d'enquête c'est malgré
la forte ambition affichée pourquoi
justement ces objectifs ne sont jamais
atteints
c'est parfait
on va essayer d'y apporter quand même
quelques réponses grâce à vous tous
en tout cas merci beaucoup de votre
prêtée à cette table ronde qui est très
intéressante on vous souhaite une bonne
soirée merci à vous tous merci pour le
travail que vous faites